house comb resumes welcome with them
beautify we're gonna wear have hair oh
my watch it's gone
this is starting a simulator with two
hands yeah so what do you get I'm
watching I am their right hand get it no
no wait wait wait we need to make sure
he's safe because then he's taken care
of I always do this to Bob me and Bob go
way back way back I I'm the only one
who's seen Bob's insights well I'm going
to now I'll have to live with that
reveal beautiful why there's so much
blood
ready well I guess because we're a
really bad doctor that's fine
no wait let me let me do the hammer
actually all right fine you can do the
hammer okay so if you yep okay don't
worry captain I got these okay how about
we grab it together yeah I got this okay
yeah then now it's all easy let you be
okay you can do it you can do it but
you're so much better there we go this
is how it's done all right I'll start
opening it up for you there we go
you're gonna be fine Bob this alarm
clock has opened many bodies before Oh
goddamn it I don't know what are you're
doing that is not a hold a hammer
okay keep doing ah this is how you
hammer mm-hmm you think you're so good
scrape it all up bottle the bottle
should do it just as fine do you does he
worry no that's a bottle and why would
do we have it I don't know I am by
profession so profession it you gotta be
careful not to hurt him cuz otherwise
he'll die and there's only one Bob out
there
and it's millions of clones yeah all
right that does that good job doctor
mighty thank you
there you go you can have the hammer
there you go it's like a pug ball give
it to Bob as his best friend this is
only fret sleep with it oh nasty
okay dad now no no it's definitely then
don't worry I can grab that Bobby's
dying there is something he's dying
we did everything we could Bob I'm so
sorry bug and I am what you say but is
my only friend and where nothing okay
okay
move okay do it you killed him you
killed him you he saw it's all your
fault
I'll show you how it's done don't worry
I'm much better than you were what's
happening to deliver I don't know it's
dancing I think it wants to escape don't
I should livermore you might hear you
might kill us
yeah okay you're all done all done all
right I need to stop the bleeding
god damn it oh I got us oh no now he's
gonna die let's dance
yeah yeah all right the syringe fell
down here somewhere I think
I can't watch me - my eyes are watery oh
we could've saved you do your thing and
stop get out mind do your everything you
do your hammer thing that's that's one
way to do it
oh yeah buddy and I all right ah yeah
right outside the syringe don't worry we
can do it anyway it's dropping a lot of
blood you know so irresponsible doing
surgery love drugs help
what are you doing exactly ah no don't
this is not his surgery uh-oh it's
dancing yes my good good job feed it to
him me too Tim he's hungry I need your
help my Jeff damn it bro
yeah feed it to him eat it Bob
you did like it's your cousin I guess
they're related somehow oh I got it I
got it
in his face now we're bleeding we
stopped the bleeding
don't cut his face so grab about it
there you go Peter - yeah we need to we
need to dig out on the rim since then
yes okay now then wait go away go away
oh god he's saying get in your heart get
the heart out you take it okay
ah dang it I'm James Rahon Danube oh
yeah I never liked you Bob never liked
you we never finished it
no no it didn't have to good let me grab
it anyway let me grab it put it in I'm
trying to reach it only my hands were
longing if only I had two hands to do
this come here Bob I love you it's her
fault I'm sorry I got it then put it in
no wait no plus one last trick okay we
can do this because I know what to do
now let me do everything too much blood
we are losing too much blood
I am there you go that was awesome you
know right all right get the last one
isn't down there I didn't have a problem
I hate this game it's so frustrating I
can't go further for some gaps for sick
and Rick what was that
okay let me take it what you took it all
right are you okay there
I'm trying really hard right now bro
this is much burden okay stop stop stop
stop sup sup sup
okay I'll inject his eye there we go
he'll be to work yes
God you need to listen I am the one I am
the one injecting his eye with drugs
you're not
trying to grow your not yours is waiting
with Siri I am doing the best job here
okay do you see why do I have a vampire
right look what big man doesn't let me
do it because I didn't like the sensor
day I got it I got this yeah Wow let's
see that Bob you see that there you go
there you go come on we got the heart
okay but my scalpel is stuck
oh god that can't be good got it okay
I'm sorry I got his tail okay
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah okay okay all right
all right let's put the heart in there
almost a okay let's grab it with me
no just meet with me damn it I need both
my hands for this come to grab it I'm
trying to it's really hard
I told it okay I'm okay I grabbed a
alright I know what fine slam-dunk I
wanted to do the same way and let's you
have like a loser
it's a be forever d is that good or bad
pretty good really what I was starting
to similar co-op we hope you enjoyed
like if you don't want us to perform
surgery on you ever and that's it for
now double brofist